how
[Music]
should I figure out what's wrong with
this audience right now I can't tell
I'm very ambivalent on whether or not
I'd like you this has been an odd set
right like like you're very quiet the
whole show and I know there's less
people here because you needed your
[ __ ] Corona bubble or whatever but
it's just an odd group of people you all
look very happy until the second I talk
to you and all of a sudden I've never
seen a more tired 11 o'clock audience in
my life the hell is wrong with Montreal
what time y'all go to bed even that boo
is shitty even the food it had no
[ __ ] energy
sound like a [ __ ] ghost in an attic
over your booing like Casper friendly
ass boo come on y'all snap Brooke clap
yo it ain't no [ __ ] coffee shop
poetry yo the hell is wrong with this
audience yeah come [ __ ] yo comedy show
you can laugh okay uptight as white
people you don't even speak real French
get over yourselves [ __ ] whooping
khwab backward-ass [ __ ] y'all speak
[ __ ] louisiana Canada a bunch of
Cajuns coming here judging me looking
down at me [ __ ] unbelievable you
think French people eat poutine [ __ ] no
they look down they got [ __ ] they look
at y'all like [ __ ] yokels oh man yeah
they just kill America got cages that's
what Montreal people are just Cajuns
with worse food
you just take all the season in that
occasion food that's Montreal
if I are getting offended you don't got
no etouffee you don't got jambalaya
you got [ __ ] bagels so kind of
[ __ ] dorky-ass food is a brag about
uh oh you must come to Montreal we have
the best circle bread suck my dick
Montreal get over your [ __ ] self
tight as uptight as judgy aspirin any
time I talk to you do I make a joke
about my fiancee who I love he's a
little kid [ __ ] stupid ass fake-ass
French accent y'all gotta [ __ ] out of
here you appropriate and asked French
people corny culture to appropriate
[ __ ] works I'm so angry
[ __ ] yo yo its québécois it's not a
language if one state speaks it all
right eat a dick butter [ __ ] Halifax
I'm like what are you saying yo didn't
cross international lines you just cross
state lines any direction they're like I
know the [ __ ] these dudes is talking
about trying to threaten Canada with
annexation they don't give a [ __ ] oh you
know what maybe we'll just be our own
country and Canada's like okay anybody
stop [ __ ] Canadians are winning
anything anyway oh good
we got the Raptors now baby with
champions don't [ __ ] clap Montreal
all right your own country ass Montreal
Oh Lennox and ass Montreal y'all got the
right to clap at Toronto I stopped
judging Toronto like you judge me look
in your [ __ ] fake French noses down
at it the [ __ ] was I talking about
before I got onto this rent
see I just [ __ ] on your whole state for
four minutes and look how quiet you are
again what'd you say don't give a [ __ ]
yo you're not better than being a state
yo [ __ ] that [ __ ] buns you suck my
dick suck my dick merci beaucoup
[ __ ] Missy [ __ ] you you put a
[ __ ] light spitting at me nothing not
[ __ ] Arabic your way come over the
back you throw so hard no [ __ ]
[ __ ] shorts in Montreal right
I'm a [ __ ] on the sulfate for the rest
of my life and it's all your fault shut
up I didn't need anything I need to say
in [ __ ] four minutes ago shut the [ __ ]
up [ __ ] you oh my god I don't know what
you said man son let me tell you
something you look like a writer barely
making it you making it and it's a
cutthroat profession but like you barely
hanging on
remember Bradley dad Bradley Cooper at
the beginning of limitless like packed
on a writer
I'm sorry ma'am mad at the rest of these
people not you it wasn't even that big
of an insult quite frankly I don't know
why they took it so cuz they're [ __ ]
these [ __ ] fake French that's the one
thing you didn't get right from the
French you're a bunch of [ __ ] what a
shitty province I might be honest this
is the most fun
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know I guess a weird note to leave
on but I also know it's not gonna get
better so I don't know what to do I'm
very torn at the moment and partly also
wants to hold you hostage because I'm
[ __ ] like you you drop something got
the [ __ ] parfait lid or something
what the [ __ ] is that yo what you eat
why you have ketchup for salsa and chips
and you're taking it home that's the
most Indian [ __ ] you could possibly do
that's so [ __ ] Indian that's such an
Indian thing to do oh damn we're cheap
dude god it's crazy out cheap